[Applaudissements]
dites nous la vérité pour nos
téléspectateurs quand vous étiez
pompiers est ce que vous avez déjà eu
une ouverture et vous avez conclu
dites moi pas loin on n'a pas le droit
mais bon nous aussi on n'a pas le droit
à ça va ça va c'est fini non sans
rigoler je le sais pas moi pendant
l'intervention
papandréou après alors comment ça c'est
fait après les numéros sur ps c'est pas
parce qu'ils sont inconscients actes et
non un truc un peu conscients
bah on avait eu une intervention où la
demoiselle était plutôt que charmante
way et en repartant s'était pas rêver à
moi par contre leur partant elle a
demandé à mon collègue son numéro et
alors il n'y a pas de données paillot
par les soirs pour lui alors il va pas
donner ces barriques et des défauts
s'appelle justement pour faire venir les
pompiers ont séduction moi j'étais en
campagne d'accord donc c'était plus
calme on a par des chats adorent y avait
il ya des gens qui ont évidemment aussi
c'est qu'il n'ya pas c'est pas il se
passe souvent ça plus dans l'est quand
ils brûlent les voitures tout ça pour
faire accroire appelé les pompiers mais
non mais non ils vont brûler une voiture
dans un champ entre acteurs ouais ça
y'est des coquins moi je me suis déjà
fait draguer par un pompier alors que je
venais de me faire
non mais c'est imaginer un genre en fait
c'est l'imaginaire de koh lanta rentrer
mais qu'on est tous ont entre mecs à la
caserne il ya deux filiales à 15 ans à l
sont prises accord c'est vrai que quand
on voit une fille tu as l'impression
qu'on a lâché un peu les chiens mais
qu'elle répète sa phrase
alors oui qu'est-ce qui se passe mais
qu'est ce que ted exactement je m'étais
fait renverser en l'occurrence et moi
j'étais vraiment pas très très bien
merci en voiture oui là c'était un accès
en voiture